so do you ever find yourself thinking
you know what I could have done this on
my own I know 100 of this this company
front end I could have done it without
it I was always going to do the business
and I think that's why they were quite
interested in the investment because
they knew I was serious whereas some
people in The Apprentice probably more
as the years have gone on aren't as
genuine about wanting to run a business
they're probably genuine about being on
TV and I was very clear to say I'm doing
this with or without you so like not in
a non-arrogant way but this is what I
built my career to do it would have
taken me longer taking me a lot longer
if I sold HRS now and did it again
tomorrow no way on Earth would I do it
this way of course I wouldn't I've now
got 11 12 years more experience than I
did then I wouldn't need that but at the
time it was right for me I was an
employee of a business I hadn't run an
independent company I hadn't set up an
independent company at the time it was
right for me